and I'll have the number 8 that's a
party platter that serves 12 people I
know what I'm about son go ahead run let
me have it
oh wait I'll do it for you I told you so
Leslie this is what happens when the
government interferes with business
government is bad business is good
free-market capitalism is the only way
Leslie it moves our country forward it's
what makes America great and England ok
and France terrible
I like capitalism I'd love competition
I'm more competitive than you
I don't think sure I think so settle
down no settle up cuz the bills been
paid and I've paid it and I won look at
the point is there has to be a way for
the government to help places that add
community value but don't necessarily
rake in the money there is not the free
market is a jungle it's beautiful and
brutal and should be left alone when a
business fails it dies and a new better
one takes its place just let business be
business and government be government
all right party time
I would suggest sticking around and
watching him eat it because it only
takes four minutes and it's pretty
amazing these will not be necessary
things did not end well between
Frederick and me oh why not
dish service Gina no I can't believe I'm
saying this but we simply don't have
time to hear about the captain sordid
romantic past what have you become a
hero at a time of crisis you stay here
and take care of Sharon well what is she
still pregnant when I get in there
then you'll deal with it sir we're going
to get Frederick right now I'm sure he's
over whatever little fight you guys had
Frederick Happy Thanksgiving who do you
think should speak first I think it
should be me and then you but if you
want it could be you and then me or it
could go me you me what do you think
about just you
thank you Ron yes tomorrow the Parks and
Rec Department is receiving a
commendation at the Indiana State House
for bringing the Harvest Festival back
and although it's purely ceremonial it's
a huge deal for me to go to the
Statehouse I couldn't care less about
the commendation
but Indianapolis is home to Charles
Mulligan's Steakhouse the best damn
Steakhouse in the damn State
I have taken a picture of every steak
I've ever eaten there June 2004
porterhouse medium-rare Bearnaise sauce
January 2000 they call this one the
enforcer February 96 a steak ribeye the
whiskey Lagavulin 16 the lady next to me
a [ __ ] specifically my ex-wife Tammy
okay this is this is the first time I
ever went there oh look at me just a kid
this is a mistake why would you call it
that on your menu and I know to tell him
in just give me all the bacon and eggs
you have wait wait I worry what you just
heard was give me a lot of bacon and
eggs what I said was give me all the
bacon and eggs you have do you
understand
please don't slam the door again we have
a bit of a medical situation I wish I
could help but unfortunately I have a
bit of a wooden duck situation excuse me
right now still on about the duck
Frederick years ago when we moved in
together and antique duck decoy of his
wasn't it placed it wasn't misplaced you
threw it in the trash and with it our
relationship no please we had other
problems or have you forgotten about
Dave Dave and I were coworkers and
nothing more nothing more right problem
solved everybody's friends let's go help
Sharon I will be happy to assist you if
you will just admit Raymond that you
threw my decoy in the garbage that will
never happen because it's not true thank
you for nothing good day
hi would you mind just standing there
with your glorious beard for one moment
I'll be right back
what the hell just tell what he wants to
hear but it's a long I don't give a crap
sir
Shara needs a doctor so get over
yourself I'm telling you threw away his
stupid duck and give him 20 bucks to buy
a new one it calls seven hundred and
forty dollars what that is an insane
price for a duck that's way too much all
right now I'm angry about the wrong
thing look just fix this for Sharon
Frederick the duck was ugly and gross
and I threw it in the garbage Wow
well I know what I'm thankful for this
Thanksgiving the truth listen I was
trying to buy this handcrafted mahogany
wood model of b-25 mitchell Panchito
aircraft for me don't sass me and I went
to this website and this ad popped up
that said hey Ron Swanson check out this
great offer what's your question my
question is what the hell like how do
they know who you are yeah okay um there
are these things called cookies where
like if you go to a site buy something
it'll remember you and then create ads
for other stuff you might want to buy so
it learns information about me seems
like an invasion of privacy dude if you
think that's bad go to Google Earth and
type in your address Terry's still not
answering his phone
why am I the only one who cares about
this baby hey what took so long is she
okay
uh yeah I was just telling her the
entire duck story now that it finally
has a satisfying ending now everything's
fine but I am a little concerned about
Sharon's blood pressure and this is a
terrible environment I would call it
terrible we're surrounded by criminals
there's no bed and you can hear the
faint sound of someone screaming through
all the vents that's Hitchcock his arm
stuck in a pneumatic tube Silurian and
my professional opinion Sharon should go
to the hospital Hey so the doctor thinks
we should go to the hospital no yep I
thought you might say that look I can't
get ahold of Terry uh Ellen was rough Oh
maybe I should listen to the doctor
what do you think Sharon it doesn't
matter what I think
you and the sorry to have a plan yeah
but the plan changed like five horrible
things ago I'm in a lot of pain I mean I
know we said no hospital but I don't
want to risk anything by making a stupid
mistake look you're my god husband we
both know that's a fake position not
anymore
what would you do where is he where's
Sara route 41 be look I'm sorry I know
you said don't go to hospital I tried
calling you you didn't pick up so you
decided to do the exact opposite of the
one thing I told you I thought it was
the right thing to do Terry look she's
in there with captain Holt's
ex-boyfriend right now but don't worry I
made him promise to stop bringing up the
duck what the hell are you talking about
you know what I'll deal with you later
seems like you already dealt with me I
got the gist we're good
I'm here for the interview about
tonight's gala yeah listen I'm a little
under the weather went on a booze cruise
last week just finished up an hour ago
on a completely unrelated note I have
horrible allergies sorry to hear that
yeah but I do need to promote this event
don't worry about me I'm a true
professional the show must go on
- hello i'm joan callamezzo today's show
will not go on seems like her allergies
are kicking in my name is Ron Swanson
I'm here to tell you about a black-tie
gala fundraiser for Pawnee Commons
happening tonight all proceeds will go
toward building a park it will be
enjoyable now I will take your calls
apparently yes hey Joan settle a bet for
me who's the sexiest couple in history
our packs in case dew or Bieber
shouldn't you be taking her to lie down
somewhere no no if she ever found out
that we took her off camera we'd all be
fired so just keep taking phone calls
you're doing great three two hello again
I'm Ron Swanson and I am still taking
your calls hopefully about tonight's
gala you're on the air hi what's wrong
with Joan she has a bad hangover which
she is pretending as allergies is she
gonna be okay wouldn't know never been
hungover after I've had too much whiskey
I cooked myself a large flank steak
pan-fried and salted butter
I eat that put on a pair of wet socks
and go to sleep that works it does
please call now if you have questions
about tonight's gala or one of my other
interests woodworking novels about tall
ships meet that sort of thing Ron
Swanson it is my pleasure to inform you
that you are a finalist for the job of
assistant city manager Chris I feel I
should remind you that I do not believe
that the position or the entire
government should exist that said you'd
be a fool not to pick me I will walk
deeper into the belly of the beast if it
means I'm able to further limit reckless
government spending I mean I have so
many ideas some are simple like take
down traffic lights and eliminate the
post office the bigger ones will be
tougher like bring all of this crumbling
to the ground
you